many Gantz was in southern Israel this
week a former army chief not for the
first time demanding stronger action
against Hamas and Islamic Jihad in Gaza
but his harshest criticism hasn't been
trained on Prime Minister Netanyahu's
security policy rather on his character
though Netanyahu look at me in the eye
look at the Israelis in the eye because
of your obsession of escaping trial you
are lying
splitting dividing mocking distributing
malicious rumors and inciting Netanyahu
you are poisoning Israel before the
tournament dances blue and white
Alliance continues to remind Israelis
should they need reminding that
Netanyahu is indicted in three separate
corruption cases warning he wants to
change Israeli law to avoid jail but
however strongly worded the message is
familiar after three campaigns in which
many mines have been made up recent
polls suggest Netanyahu taking a narrow
lead and I think is the right man for us
many guns okay now I will hope for some
change in three campaigns now Bennigan's
has been trying to make the argument
that israel needs to rid itself of a
prime minister mired in corruption
charges and he's been given a gift this
time round with the trial date set for
just two weeks after polling day and yet
that argument doesn't seem to be getting
the traction that he needs this campaign
has seen a rightward shift in tone and
policy with Gant's backing the
controversial Trump peace plan at least
as a starting point for talks seeking to
prize voters away from Benjamin
Netanyahu's laocoon Netanyahu meanwhile
is using a well-worn playbook warning
Jewish voters that Gantz only has one
way to form a minority government and it
should frighten them guns not your horn
against will not be able to create a
government without the support of F met
Tyrion the joint lists in the Knesset he
cannot this is what they are trying to
conceal ganses distanced himself from
the palestinian-israeli group of parties
saying he doesn't need their support the
bacon back whoever they want they're not
very happy with him but they're not and
if being somewhat at odds with them
gives him more credibility to draw some
votes from
across the middle from the Nataniel
territory you know that's the the logic
of what he's been doing a year and three
election campaigns into his political
career been against now has plenty of
on-the-job training
but Israeli politics still seems
stubbornly stuck just days away from
polling he may even have to come back
for a fourth attempt later this year
Harry Fawcett al Jazeera West Jerusalem